balance in video games is always a
contentious issue and players are quick
to voice their opinions on any changes
developers make especially when it
affects them personally when something
has made weaker in a video game we call
it a nerf but where did that expression
come from and why has the term gained
such massive popularity to find out we
have to travel back in time to 1997 the
easiest just got easier
it's the messages I can customize my
email my need sent me a picture if you
have a phone line you can be online it's
the easiest way to keep up with old
friends it's hard to overstate how
different the internet was back then
about 37% of American households had
home computers and only 18 percent of
them had internet access along with the
first clone sheep starfox 64 and 56k
modems 1997 saw the release of ultima
online a massively multiplayer online
role-playing game or MMORPG it was a new
breed of game one that offered
possibilities unlike its predecessors
and because of the persistent world it
also had to adapt to its players
it was very broken upon launch and and
one of the first things is we're here
scrambling to get to catch up with stuff
we realized that people are both really
upset and really passionate about being
there you know if they if they were
upset an OP that could just quit and go
away somewhere else but these people
weren't quitting and going away they
cared they cared they were in the game
protesting in the game at one point in
Ultima Online swords were toned down to
be a little less effective the response
from some players was that they felt
like nerf weapons instead of actual
blades the term nerf soon became
shorthand for anything that was rendered
less effective due to a game update and
it makes a lot of sense it's easier to
say it was nerfed instead of saying
banelings changes made my character
weaker or something like that but it's
easy to forget that there was a time
when nerfs were a lot more difficult to
implement titles like Street Fighter 3
which had long lived competitive
had to release completely new versions
of the game to change anything even so
the last version of the game third
strike had two extremely overpowered
characters in Ken and chun-li had Capcom
been able to patch the game would we
have seen the ever iconic evil moment
3710 and chun-li
would have been obvious targets for
nerves so who knows today the Internet
has made patching games easier than ever
that means games can be updated more
frequently but it also means that nerfs
are inescapable well [__] that the fact
that balance changes are not always
explained and that developers often have
different views of the game's balance
than players has also led to the terms
development as a meme in early league of
legends the champion irelia was nerfed
over and over while other champions
perceived as stronger weren't changed as
quickly this gave rise to the meme
better nor fir Elia a sarcastic response
to basically anything implying that riot
would nerf the champion for theological
reasons were even no reason at all
rather than nerfing the champions that
needed it sometimes though memes don't
represent reality though better nerf
irelia stuck around the champion didn't
actually suffer that many nerves after
the early years of law a fact that TSM's
the odd one discovered on streams last
time even the nerd I'm gonna go look it
up let's all like a right now what what
she wasn't even [__] doesn't even
[__] nerfed
holy [__] Arella players are geniuses
like she doesn't even get [__] nerve
does our urban buffs some game
developers like Blizzard Entertainment
haven't shied away from community
sensitivity around character balancing
in over watts they've even gone as far
as acknowledging it in game with
self-referential humor I reached out to
Hasbro to find out how they felt about
the nerf trademark being used to
describe things that were made worse
unsurprisingly they didn't respond
although I did find a Nerf dart in my
driveway the other day so there you have
it nerves now an inescapable fact of
gaming life here's the hoping none are
headed your way
on lesser Jase player in which case [__]
you okay how is that pretty good but
Hasbro send their regards
[Music]
you got nerfed thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button
[Music]